women's rights have come a long way in
the eu
let's take a look at some of the
milestones along the road to equality
long before the european union was born
european leaders were already
laying the groundwork for gender
equality
in 1957 they signed the treaty of rome
it made gender equality a fundamental
value of the european community
in 1975 the council of the european
communities adopted the principle of
equal pay for women
after the first direct european
elections in 1979
parliament set about choosing its
president and elected a woman
[Applause]
in its second term in 1984 parliament
established its committee on women's
rights
[Music]
in 2000 the eu published its charter of
fundamental rights
it states that equality between women
and men must be insured in all areas
in 2014 meps adopted a directive to
combat violence against women and human
trafficking
violence against women is a severe
violation of human rights in a form of
gender-based discrimination
it is the root cause of gender
inequality in 2019
mep set out to improve work-life balance
in the eu
with rules on parental leave flexible
working arrangements and
time off for carers
40 of the seats in the 2019 european
elections
with the spread of clovid19 meps
highlighted the plight of women in the
pandemic
we must make team europe a shining light
for women and girls across the world
a byword for a brighter post-covert
future
in 2021 parliament called for measures
to protect women's rights
and ensure they are protected against
domestic violence during
and after the crisis
foreign
the european parliament is now pushing
for a more ambitious gender equality
strategy
focusing on ending gender-based violence
and closing gender gaps
once and for